now to a developing story out of the US
and there have been multiple casualties
after a mass shooting in the state of
Maine it happened at several locations
in the city of Lewiston Police say the
gunman is still on the Run let's go to
John hendin who's covering developments
for us out of Washington DC hello there
John what more are you hearing about
this shooting we understand that he's
the shooter has been named by police
talk us through the latest
developments
that's right authorities in Maine have
identified the gunman is Robert card
they say he was born in 1983 that would
make him 40 years old and they say he
has a history of mental health problems
was Rel recently released from a mental
health facility and that among other
things he's had a problem hearing voices
what makes that combination dangerous is
that he's also a trained Firearms
instructor and you can see in the
pictures there that police have released
that what he's caring in is clearly an
assault weapon he has killed so far we
are told 22 people and injured 50 at at
least three dis different locations
there was a Walmart Distribution Center
a bar and restaurant called shimis and
then a bowling alley and he's still on
the loose police are still looking for
him they say he's driving uh 2013 Subaru
and he's a wanted man now what makes
that weapon so significant is that from
1990 to 2000 Congress passed an assault
weapons ban among those people who push
that ban was now president then Senator
Joe Biden that would make the weapon
used in this case potentially banned now
there was a grandfather clause that
allowed other weapons to be used but
this is the eighth deadliest shooting so
far in US history so it surpasses those
in Parkland Florida and other major
shootings that we've all reported far
too many times on this network so police
are still looking for this man he is
still on the loose he is both dangerous
and he's had a history of mental health
problems far too many times indeed thank
you so much for bringing us up to speed
John hendin in Washington
DC